>> FELLOW AMERICANS, GOOD
MORNING.
CERTAIN DATES ECHO THROUGHOUT
HISTORY, INCLUDING DATES THAT
INSTANTLY REMIND ALL WHO HAVE
LIVED THROUGH THEM WHERE THEY
WERE, AND WHAT THEY WERE DOING
WHEN OUR DEMOCRACY CAME UNDER
ASSAULT.
DATES THAT OCCUPY NOT ONLY A
PLACE ON OUR CALENDARS, BUT A
PLACE IN OUR COLLECTIVE MEMORY.
DECEMBER 7 th, 1941, SEPTEMBER
11th, 2001, AND JANUARY 6th,
2021.
ON THAT DAY, I WAS NOT ONLY VICE
PRESIDENT-ELECT, I WAS ALSO A
UNITED STATES SENATOR.
AND I WAS HERE AT THE CAPITOL
THAT MORNING AT A CLASSIFIED
HEARING WITH FELLOW MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
HOURS LATER, THE GATES OF THE
CAPITOL WERE BREACHED.
I HAD LEFT, BUT MY THOUGHTS
IMMEDIATELY TURNED NOT ONLY TO
MY COLLEAGUES, BUT TO MY STAFF,
WHO HAD BEEN FORCED TO SEEK
REFUGE IN OUR OFFICE, CONVERTING
FILING CABINETS INTO BARRICADES.
WHAT THE EXTREMISTS WHO ROAMED
THESE HALLS TARGETED WAS NOT
ONLY THE LIVES OF ELECTED
LEADERS, WHAT THEY SOUGHT TO
DEGRADE AND DESTROY WAS NOT ONLY
A BUILDING, HALLOWED AS IT IS,
WHAT THEY WERE ASSAULTING WERE
THE INSTITUTIONS, THE VALUES,
THE IDEALS, THAT GENERATIONS OF
AMERICANS HAVE MARCHED,
PICKETED, AND SHED BLOOD TO
ESTABLISH AND DEFEND.
ON JANUARY 6th, WE ALL SAW WHAT
OUR NATION WOULD LOOK LIKE IF
THE FORCES WHO SEEK TO DISMANTLE
OUR DEMOCRACY ARE SUCCESSFUL.
THE LAWLESSNESS, THE VIOLENCE,
THE CHAOS.
WHAT WAS AT STAKE THEN AND NOW
IS THE RIGHT TO HAVE OUR FUTURE
DECIDED THE WAY THE CONSTITUTION
PRESCRIBES IT, BY WE, THE
PEOPLE.
ALL THE PEOPLE.
WE CANNOT LET OUR FUTURE BE
DECIDED BY THOSE BENT ON
SILENCING OUR VOICES,
OVERTURNING OUR VOTES, AND
PEDALING LIES AND
MISINFORMATION.
BY SOME RADICAL FACTION THAT MAY
BE NEWLY RESURGENT, BUT WHOSE
ROOTS RUN OLD AND DEEP.
WHEN I MEET WITH YOUNG PEOPLE,
THEY OFTEN ASK ABOUT THE STATE
OF OUR DEMOCRACY, ABOUT JANUARY
6th, AND WHAT I TELL THEM IS
JANUARY 6th REFLECTS THE DUAL
NATURE OF DEMOCRACY, ITS
FRAGILITY AND ITS STRENGTH.
YOU SEE, THE STRENGTH OF
DEMOCRACY IS THE RULE OF LAW.
THE STRENGTH OF DEMOCRACY IS THE
PRINCIPLE THAT EVERYONE SHOULD
BE TREATED EQUALLY, THAT
ELECTIONS SHOULD BE FREE AND
FAIR, THAT CORRUPTION SHOULD BE
GIVEN NO QUARTER.
THE STRENGTH OF DEMOCRACY IS
THAT IT EMPOWERS THE PEOPLE.
AND THE FRAGILITY OF DEMOCRACY
IS THIS, THAT IF WE ARE NOT
VIGILANT, IF WE DO NOT DEFEND
IT, DEMOCRACY SIMPLY WILL NOT
STAND.
IT WILL FALTER, AND FAIL.
THE VIOLENT ASSAULT THAT TOOK
PLACE HERE, THE VERY FACT OF HOW
CLOSE WE CAME TO AN ELECTION
OVERTURNED, THAT REFLECTS THE
FRAGILITY OF DEMOCRACY.
YET THE RESOLVE I SAW IN OUR
ELECTED LEADERS, WHEN I RETURNED
TO THE SENATE CHAMBER THAT
NIGHT, THEIR RESOLVE NOT TO
YIELD, BUT TO CERTIFY THE
ELECTION, THEIR LOYALTY NOT TO
PARTY OR PERSON, BUT TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES, THAT REFLECTS ITS
STRENGTH.
AND SO, OF COURSE, DOES THE
HEROISM OF THE CAPITOL POLICE,
THE D.C. METROPOLITAN POLICE
DEPARTMENT, THE NATIONAL GUARD
AND OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHO ANSWERED THE CALL
THAT DAY, INCLUDING THOSE WHO
LATER SUCCUMBED TO WOUNDS, BOTH
VISIBLE AND INVISIBLE.
OUR THOUGHTS ARE WITH ALL OF THE
FAMILIES WHO HAVE LOST A LOVED
ONE.
YOU KNOW, I WONDER HOW WILL
JANUARY 6th COME TO BE
REMEMBERED IN THE YEARS AHEAD?
WILL IT BE REMEMBERED AS A
MOMENT THAT ACCELERATED THE
UNRAVELING OF THE OLDEST,
GREATEST DEMOCRACY IN THE WORLD?
OR A MOMENT WHEN WE DECIDED TO
SECURE AND STRENGTHEN OUR
DEMOCRACY FOR GENERATIONS TO
COME.
THE AMERICAN SPIRIT IS BEING
TESTED.
THE ANSWER TO WHETHER WE WILL
MEET THAT TEST RESIDES WHERE IT
ALWAYS HAS RESIDED IN OUR
COUNTRY.
WITH YOU, THE PEOPLE.
AND THE WORK AHEAD WILL NOT BE
EASY.
HERE IN THIS VERY BUILDING, A
DECISION WILL BE MADE ABOUT
WHETHER WE UPHOLD THE RIGHT TO
VOTE AND ENSURE FREE AND FAIR
ELECTIONS.
LET'S BE CLEAR, WE MUST PASS
VOTING RIGHTS BILLS THAT ARE NOW
BEFORE THE SENATE.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE MUST
ALSO DO SOMETHING MORE.
WE CANNOT SIT ON THE SIDELINES,
WE MUST UNITE IN DEFENSE OF OUR
DEMOCRACY IN ORDER TO FORM A
MORE PERFECT UNION, ESTABLISH
JUSTICE, ENSURE DOMESTIC
TRANQUILITY, PROVIDE FOR THE
COMMON DEFENSE, PROMOTE THE
GENERAL WELFARE, AND SECURE THE
BLESSINGS OF LIBERTY TO
OURSELVES AND TO OUR PROSPERITY
AND POSTERITY.
THAT IS THE PREAMBLE OF THE
CONSTITUTION, THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND I SWORE AN OATH